الحواسيب الكمية مصممة لحل مشكلات ما تقدر
الحواسيب الكلاسيكية تتعامل معها
زي إيجاد المواد المناسبة لتمكين
احتجاز الكربون بشكل فعلي
لمواجهة تغير المناخ، ولمعالجة
الأسمدة الأكثر كفاءة اللي ممكن
ما تأذي الأرض وفي نفس الوقت تحافظ على
سلسلة الغذاء اللي نحتاجها لإطعام العالم
وكمان في أسئلة جوهرية عن كيف تركّب كوننا
وكيف تتصرف المادة على المستوى الذري
ودون الذري وهذا شيء لازم نعرفه
هذه هي الحدود الجديدة
خلينا نأخذ مجال واحد البحث فيه شغّال هلق
البحث عن بطاريات جديدة
البطاريات غيّرت حياتنا بأنها خلّتنا نحمل
حواسيب وهواتف ذكية
بس في المزيد اللي لازم يتعمل فالبطاريات أساسية
لمستقبلنا في الطاقة النظيفة
سواء في تشغيل السيارات الكهربائية فعلياً
أو دفع الطاقة المتجددة للأمام
نحتاج كيمياء مختلفة من الأساس
لصناعة البطاريات
اللي راح نحتاجها في المستقبل، والحوسبة الكمية
تقدر تخلينا نطل فعلياً داخل البطارية
أثناء تفاعلاتها المعقدة جداً لنقدر
نفكر في مواد جديدة
وبنية البطاريات اللي راح تكون ضرورية
لتشغيل الجيل القادم من الأجهزة
كيف نوصل لهذا؟ بتطوير أكثر أجهزة الحوسبة الكمية تقدماً
ومنصة تطوير متكاملة
وإتاحتها للعالم
فقط بالتعاون مع بعض الآن
راح نقدر نحل المشكلات اللي راح نواجهها
مع بعض في المستقبل.